so you've been part of every medium at
this point
you've done uh obviously broadway uh
and your your shows what what excites
you the most like is there a particular
medium where you're like hey i think i
want to invest more energy in in this
direction i'm really
falling in love with theater again and
the possibility of theater and i'd love
to see like long day's journey tonight
in
all latin cast or street partnering
desire and
all latin cast because we have the
population in the triboro area to keep
that sucker funded for
for years i think it's a great place to
be challenged as a as an artist because
it's the most difficult it's the
olympics
of acting that's for damn sure there's
no cutting there's no editing
there's nothing going to save you except
your skill set
[Music]
on today's episode of yang speaks actor
and comedian john leguizamo is joining
you guys don't want to miss this he is a
fascinating guy tune in john leguizamo
on yang speaks right now
[Music]
[Applause]
it is my pleasure and privilege to
welcome
to yang speaks my friend one of the
great artists
of this era tony award winner
been in oh my gosh what is it man like
80 movies 100 movies
uh director producer stand up comedian
john leguizamo welcome john that's so
great thank you
thank you you've got the knicks cap on
am i right that you actually just
attended
the greatest sporting event in recent
memory which is the knicks playoff
victory in the garden
the other night did that happen oh my
god eight years
that we have not been in the playoffs
and this
year pandemic and all of a sudden we're
in madison square garden
at almost like what 90 capacity
people it was was screaming and yelling
and hollering
and loving i mean it was incredible man
the energy was
unbeatable it was it was it was better
than the game
even though we won i want to hear all
about this so first uh who did you bring
to the game did you go with friends you
go with family like my wife my wife
my wife justin well well this is an
incredible date then this is very
exciting
and then do you do the vip treatment
experience or just like walk in or like
what like what did you do yeah you know
yeah we got little
we got little juice we got a little
juice
i'm not gonna front we got some swag so
we you know we walk in
we got courtside seats but you have to
have to test even though you double
backs or or
whatever you still have to test an hour
before and test negative
and you still have to wear a mask if
you're going to be that close to the
players
but you know it was fun i was hanging
out with sting
and victor cruz
there was a ton of folk there man chris
maloney
uh john mcenroe and his brother patrick
yeah
hobnobbing with the best yeah cause
because all in new york city is coming
out for this game uh you know nick's
being back in the playoffs
you got the court side treatment that's
incredible and you and i probably had a
similar experience we can share this for
a minute
um where you grew up in jackson heights
in the queens area and so
um you probably did the same thing i did
which is um every once in a while you
get lucky and get some like nosebleed
seats
for like a while yeah yeah you'd end up
um so i remember that very well
how about the shea stadium when it used
to be around because i'm a little older
than all y'all
i'm older than dirt now and uh we used
to
stand on the subway platform to watch
and hear the game
those are ghetto seats
[Laughter]
uh i remember shea stadium uh i remember
the subway platform and like it being
shown on tv and all the fans like you
know having a good time out out there
um i remember for the garden there was a
period
john where they actually sold ten dollar
knicks tickets to games
and they went they went like this it was
in the late 90s early 2000s
um and believe it or not i managed to
get my hands on like some ten dollar
tickets
and so you'd be there and it was like
you know the worst seats in the house
but
one thing you got to say about the
garden there really aren't many bad
seats like you could sit pretty much in
that place
that's also when you when you don't know
from courtside
it's all good it's until you know what
court-sided vip treatment is that it
then it hurts
i started out in the nosebleeds then
every once in a while a friend who works
in you know banking or something would
be like yeah
you know the 200 levels and then you'd
like go back
it's funny it's that i think that that's
an experience that a lot of
new yorkers have which is like you know
just the random night when your friend
calls you and is like hey i've got these
yeah yeah tickets
and you got and you got some other great
tickets or some other like hamilton
[ __ ] and then you're like oh man not
tonight
not tonight great courtside next tickets
and i got hamilton which i couldn't get
you know it always happens like that too
when it rains and pours that game i
think it might be the largest group of
people that have been together in one
building or one room in new york city in
a year yep
yeah no it's wild man you were literally
like in the place like the heart of the
action
but say that you're completely safe
feeling so safe because
they have a system you know i mean
everybody has to be double vaxxed
everybody has to be
you know uh tested everybody's got their
masks you know you just feel
incredibly safe uh so the game you were
at
like trae young had a great game but
came a little bit short
and i i i mean i was stunned in game one
when uh you know when trey young hit
that game winner and whatnot and like
he really he he reminded me of reggie
miller during like yeah the next
days when when he became like the
villain of the garden i was like yeah
honestly i was like i did not know
trayong had this in him
man i know i didn't know he like he's
like a step on curry i mean he's so good
in every
in every position and everything that
he's doing and i i know he's follicly
challenged
but i love that about him too that the
hair ain't perfect and whatnot
it makes him even more lovable because
he's got superhuman powers when he
becomes a b-ball
trey is not very big right like i've
never met trey
well he's still going to take both seems
like you know he can still
take you andrew don't get don't no i
mean i'm
oh he's six one six two he seems like a
normal human out there among like the
trees and whatnot
he looks tiny he look he looks uh kind
of like uh
you know like a hobbit but but he ain't
he'll make us he'll make us hobbit like
are you a nets fan at all i mean you're
obviously much
more harder core knicks fan like how do
you feel about the nets oh
i'm loving the nets this year i mean i
love kyrie i love katie
you know i i love the i love their team
man the team is beautiful i mean
you know new yorkers that we're not
allowed to you know you have to have
your loyalty
and you can't even cross you know i
can't i can't i can't root for the
yankees because my meds fan otherwise
people freak out
you know what i mean yeah but i don't
know sometimes new york is new york you
know i i i
you know if we don't make it and then
let's make it i'm going to go to ned's
game i mean you just want new york to do
well
yeah large right because it has
repercussions you know and you feel it
across the city
when the yankees when the whole city is
electric you know yeah
so you've been at this for quite a while
um and one of the things i always love
to ask people like you or world-class
creatives
is how the heck you got started because
i feel like getting started in
in your field is like the hardest thing
in the world you know
like like you you grow yeah like you you
go to the local high school
yeah um you know in your case i think
you attended nyu for a minute and then
dropped out
uh to pursue comedy uh i i want to say
yeah i mean being latin back then and
being wanting to be an actor
was was not the most successful looking
choice
because you know they just didn't cast
us they didn't cast us no matter what we
always cast it out you know
uh never made it you know like all my
white friends that were at nyu studying
acting were going to like
five editions a day i was going to one
every five months
so i saw i saw i saw you you must have
felt that so acutely because you're all
in this program and you're like wait a
minute like you know that like like
there just aren't as many roles that's
fascinating that's crazy yeah i was able
to see it firsthand i was going wow why
why don't i have the same options i
study like them i have the same grades
i studied with better acting teachers
than they did i say with herbert
berghoff and lee strasbourg why don't i
have the same opportunities
because of the way i look in my name and
uh
that came you know became a realization
really fast and then i knew
you know i started to learn that wow
this is this is going to be very
difficult
and i i need to find other ways to to
stay
you know sane and stay creative so i
started writing
because that's one place nobody could
stop me you know nobody can tell me no
or or
so the stuff you started writing
initially was it comedy was it jokes
like what did you start out writing
yeah you know i was writing jokes in
high school because i had a very
competitive comedy table at lunch and
you couldn't sit at the table unless you
had
the best jokes and if you didn't have
the day before you weren't allowed to
set the table
so it's not competitive so i used to
have to write jokes to be able to win
because you can't just
you know be improvising you're not going
to come up with the top joke
so yes i started writing then and then
by the time i graduated college i
started uh writing uh sort of uh
characters
sketches you know uh i was doing improv
at the first amendment which was this
big
downtown improv comedy group that was
huge you know bruce willis went there
rob williams would come there and
you know and and a lot of communities
would come there and steal jokes too
that that was a
a real thing i learned too i mean some
of your jokes they probably couldn't
steal because it wouldn't make sense for
them because i'm sure some of them had
to do with being latino
people people are clever though
comedians they
[Laughter]
so you're scrapping and clawing for a
while in the new york comedy scene like
when did you feel like okay
like this is gonna work you know like
i'm gonna make it
uh where you started having like uh some
success and getting cast in various
roles like what what would you consider
your own breakout
my breakthrough moment uh when
everything
just fell into place was when i did my
first one-man show called mama mouth in
1990
and uh you know they didn't really
believe in my show they kind of believed
in my show
because i was in the hallway of the
theater i wasn't even in the theater i
was in the hallway of the theater
with a makeshift platform 70 fold up
seats
that they would pick up at eight o'clock
when the real show started
and and i had to be god you know all my
audience had to be cleared out
but you know the reviews came in and
you know they were banging you know and
all of a sudden in in this 70 fold of
seats was al pacino
uh john f k jr uh
olympia dukakis raul julia sam
shepard arthur miller uh john malkovich
it was incredible man and then that
that's
when everything started to change
because i think
i learned the audience was learning the
industry was learning
wow latin content is valuable
latin content is for everybody let
people want to see latin people latin
people definitely want to see themselves
so it was a breakthrough moment
culturally
it must have been such a small venue too
where you could literally see their
faces you'd be looking
to be like hey look it's always getting
nervous
i would get nervous sometimes because my
sight was good then
and i could see those faces and
sometimes you know they're not they're
looking at you but they're getting tired
or sleepy or or whatever i don't know
yeah yeah you know you see all that
people yawn sometimes you know
sometimes i'm glad now that i can't see
because i
all the audience looks like they're
really just loving it i'm gonna tell a
random story
from running for president that's like
my parallel and you know like uh
you know it's a little bit later on or
whatnot um but you you have a town hall
in new hampshire and you can see
everyone's face
so so there there's like this like real
like yeah you kind of know if it's going
well or not it's one reason why you see
these various political figures being
like okay
like change it up because you see what's
working what's not working
and then i look out there and then it's
like paul jamadi sitting there and i get
distracted i'm like oh [ __ ] paul
jamadi's
like new hampshire
and then you're like block it out just
do you say what you're saying but then
there's like part of you i just wanted
to stop and be like hey
you know right right yours from you know
like what you know whatever movie i saw
he went
especially when you see your heroes it's
like when i saw a patina i was like you
know i
i i heard myself stammer because here's
your hero
watching you perform it's it's it's a
little too much
you know i mean it's a little too much
well in your case it must have felt
like such an incredible vindication or
nighting where like they're like kind of
letting you in the club where like some
people who are heroes of yours who are
world-class new york creatives actually
took time out
saw your show and then you get all these
great reviews from the material i can
see why you're like wow
you know like uh like this is working
and you were what 26 at the time is that
right
yeah i was 26 and uh yeah they gave me
the confidence
to keep going and then boom i wrote my
next show spicarama
and uh i won best play of 1992 at
warner hall award and uh
you know those those little wins were
really important to me
because it fueled me you know it fueled
me and and then when my show mama mouth
hit hbo
then the latin audience found me and
they would
go everywhere i went chicago san
francisco
texas wherever i would go there was a
huge latin audience
to be had and you know they just made a
church you know it would they would be
calling response and
yelling and hooting hollering and it
became electric
that's beautiful you must have felt so
welcomed by the
uh latino community uh the whole time
because you are
one of the most prominent voices uh in
my mind in the industry and when you got
started there was
probably a massive void or vacuum you
were filling
but you know one of the things it
reminds me of a little bit is i have
some folks who are
uh asian american creatives and whatnot
and some of them also talked about like
hey i i only i
get cast as the waiter the gangster
like that right right like whatever the
asian american roles are i know i i i bd
wong used to tell me about those stories
you know
like here's this massively talented
young man
and you know his opportunities are nil
you know
just waiting for that perfect asian role
to come along you know
i love the way um whoopi goldberg did it
like when she hit stardom
she was also a big influence for me
brilliant brilliant performer i saw that
her show that mike nichols directed on
broadway was life-changing for me
but she had them change white rolls and
male roles
to make them a black woman just take any
script and boom she her her recipe was
just make it a black woman
and i was like yeah
just make it a black woman that's a
pretty good system you know i think
people are listening to this and being
like yeah let's just like make this yeah
an asian dude
right because hollywood didn't
understand hollywood didn't understand
how to write for a black woman they
didn't know
how to create that form to create
product for her so she said
just take a goddamn regular
[ __ ] script and make it about a
black woman it just
and it worked it worked yeah whoopi and
i became friends over the last number of
months um
you know uh through through the view uh
during the presidential she's been great
um she's awesome she and i got into a
lot of trouble
with with al gore was running for
president she and i did the dnc
and both of us had ron raunchy raunchy
material
and and we got the dnc in so much
trouble because both of us for some
reason
decided to go like blue and rogue at the
same time and it was too much
but yeah they couldn't handle it people
would call it going
those are different times too and oh
yeah when you show up in person to the
dnc
uh it was a probably a very very boring
crew because i've been to these dnc
things and
like yeah
it was so wrong but i learned i learned
i never did
yeah next i think i did the john kerry
one and i just really toned it down
that's really funny you were like i'm
just gonna play this one right up the
middle
maybe yeah yeah no it wasn't a place to
be wrong she was like oh my bad i read
the room wrong
i remember when um i was
meant to speak at the dnc uh
convention this past year and you
actually feel a bit of pressure because
you're like well the ratings for this
are going to be sky high and you know
you were very very tightly controlled in
terms of
time um and and so we had a speech that
we prepared
and then they gave notes and the only
notes they gave john were just trying to
cut words
they're just trying to like make stuff
shorter it's just like whatever it is is
making sure
like substance like they were cool with
the substance yeah yeah and
and then they had me into practice the
the dnc speech which is a weird feeling
because you're like practicing
speaking to the american people and they
also tell
that hey if there's any technical
difficulty we're just going to play this
recording
so it was like a weird dress rehearsal
where you're like all right like
let me like um give me my best
yeah let me rub five people in the house
as i'm talking to america
and then be prepared to be cut out yeah
yeah like that that's what it was and
then like time passed it was like the
real one
and um it was it was from a studio in
new york in that case and it was like uh
me and cory booker were in the same
studio so
we were um sharing some time and
shooting this [ __ ] uh
how great is he man isn't corey great i
mean he's got such a great boss he's a
great guy
[Music]
okay i like you live a very busy as we
all do very busy stressful lives
and when you don't have a good mattress
to come home to and crash on it sucks
and i'm grateful that
uh we've partnered with helix sleep and
i've been using a helix mattress and
sleeping on it and it's amazing
helix sleep is awesome and here's how
they work they give you like this two
minute sleep quiz
you fill it out based on your
preferences you like a softer for a
mattress you sleep on your side you turn
your neck do you sleep hot whatever it
is
and they match you with the perfect
mattress i got this king mattress you
get the perfect balance for me it's the
helix lux the california king it's
freaking massive
and i love it to death and it's not just
me helix was awarded number one best
overall mattress pick
in 2020 by gq and wired magazine
literally the people that rate
mattresses for a living pick this number
one
multiple times so here's the deal go to
helixsleep.com
yang take their two minute sleep quiz
and they'll match you to a customized
mattress that will get you the best
sleep of your life
for real they got a 10-year warranty you
get to try it out for 100 nights
risk-free they'll even pick it up for
you if you don't love it but you're
going to
when they ship it to you in this
beautiful box comes out roll it out
um super easy super awesome so right now
they're offering
up to 200 off all mattress orders and
two free pillows for our listeners at
helixsleep.com
yang that's helix h-e-l-i-x sleep.com
yang for up to 200 off and two free
pillows check it out
[Music]
[Applause]
i feel like a couple of the big movie
roles i started you know like
where you became a household name were
romeo and juliet and then moulin rouge
and i got to say i was like a big big
baslerman fan from back then
so i don't know i was just curious yeah
no i was curious about
whether those experiences stuck out for
you in some way because i feel like
you know the fact that you work with
some filmmakers more than once means
there's some kind of artistic connection
or relationship
yeah i gotta say i feel very proud of
myself that i worked
twice and sometimes three times a lot of
filmmakers i feel like
they get me they get that i'm not about
ego or vanity or narcissism i'm just
about to work
and i want to do the best work and i
want everybody to do their
their best work and and i come to the
game to play that way
uh and and with baz who's the most
collaborative
director i've ever worked with because
he wants to know your
opinion he wants to know what you want
to add to the situation and he welcomes
it from everybody
from the crew i've never seen a director
work like that and i
and i borrow from him greatly and he
rehearses a lot which is another
really important thing that only the
great directors i've seen do like spike
lee did it with us with the summer sammy
rehearsed for two weeks
uh uh brian de palma also rehearsed this
for uh casualties of war and um
in carlito's way did the great directors
know i mean it's mostly for theater but
nobody else does it
and and for moulin rouge we did a month
rehearsal like i had to learn
how to speak with a sort of english
accent in the lift because
tousa trek uh was a product of two first
cousins so
his lips and tongue were kind of like
cartilagey
and then he had weak ankles he had a lot
a lot of physical issues
uh being the product of two first
cousins so there's a lesson
for anybody and everybody you know
don't mess around with family that way
but but working with baz i mean
it's incredible man i mean some of the
scenes had 21 angles so you had to do it
like
40 50 times which is really intense
and then you saw that final product i
mean moulin rouge is
is brought the musical back and been
dead since 1972 greece was the last
successful musical 1972 and here he is
bringing it back 2000
and it came back so you've been
part of every medium at this point
you've done
uh obviously broadway uh and your your
shows
you've been like the voice out of ice
age and the rest of it
you've been in movies been in tv at this
point i feel like you could do
anything like what type of role
uh whether it's like director producer
writer like
what excites you the most like is there
a particular medium where you're like
hey i think i
want to invest more energy in in this
direction because at this point i feel
like
people are going to want you for like
you know like all of the above like is
there a particular
area that you're more excited about yeah
there is i mean i'm really falling in
love with theater again
and the possibility of theater and and
especially because i'm in new york city
and i and i just had so much success in
la and new york
uh you know uh to bring theater i would
love to see like long day's journey
tonight in
all latin cast or street partnering
desire and
all latin cast because we have the
population in the triboro area to keep
that sucker funded for
for years look at my dog back there
it looks like a corp looks like a corpse
[Laughter]
but yeah i would love i would love to go
back to theater i think it's a great
place
to be challenged as an artist because
it's the most difficult it's the
olympics
of acting that's for damn sure there's
no cutting there's no editing
there's nothing going to save you except
your skill set
well one of the things that i talked to
folks like you about
um is that i've discovered parallels
among politics comedy performance of
different
uh different types and so i i'll be
asking folks like
like you if someone were to run for our
senate or president
from the creative fields like who might
you pick out and be like oh that that
person could do it so
so to preface this i'll tell you about a
couple people who have been called out
to me in this
direction someone said jon stewart
someone was like jon stewart could you
could do this at like a very very high
level
um another person nominated uh
chris rock
yeah yeah why not um
man i think i think alec has the chops
the
the intelligence the savvy i mean he
just
so well-rounded you know what i mean and
he's got that great
choice he's got to be especially because
he because he played
he played the president over and over
again and and at this point
in our in our country i feel like if you
play the president
that's like halfway to
so you're investing in theater there's
like a show that
i want to say that you're uh in right
now or soon to be is it like a waiting
for godot revival with ethan hall oh
yeah
yeah yeah uh it's the first time it's
the play has ever been allowed to be
filmed
and it's only allowed to live on this
platform for three weeks and then we
have to destroy it um
because the estate wait wait wait you
have to destroy it oh yeah yeah
it was a one time only thing because of
the pandemic and the situation we're
living that the estate the godot state
the back of the state
allowed us to film it because it's never
been allowed to be filmed
uh and and you know they have a lot of
rules like we're not allowed to cut the
script you're not allowed to change
any words you have to stick exactly to
what beckett wrote
so we had that but i i thought
ethan hawke was incredible in it while
shawn is so beautiful tariq kills it
i think this is one of the best godot
versions i've i've ever seen
not just because i'm in it but because
sometimes it gets a little too silly to
play for me it gets a little too
ridiculous and
and you just lose all the values we
really
researched a lot and tried to understand
that
beckett wanted the depression the
depressing elements to live
the the anger the the the the
being lost the because it's right after
the war so
people were hungry they were homeless
they
they they were lost you know everything
had been destroyed europe was bombed all
over the place
this does sound like kind of familiar to
our time a little bit yeah and we're
coming out of it yeah yeah
exactly andrew exactly that's why we did
it now because we felt it it was such a
parallel to
to our feeling you know jobless and and
confused and alone and isolated kind of
like the way people felt after world war
ii
so the shows that you have in mind uh
for
new york city it sounds like they would
have
latino latina cast uh involved are there
particular productions you have your
your um mind like
uh moving towards like are there things
that you you
we can look forward to i suppose or is
it in the planning stage still
oh no it's on the planet stages but uh
you know i i'd love to see a long day's
journey tonight
who's afraid of virginia woolf for the
all latin cast
definitely a salesman yeah those i want
to see the classics
with latin people in it because i think
it would really change
everybody's perceptions of of of latin
life and latin people you know and and
seeing performers and we know we have
we have the crowds you know you have the
talent that's for sure you're the talent
oh yeah because
we got definitely got the talent you
know uh and we definitely have the
audience i mean 30
where we're equal to whites in
population in new york city
and uh so yeah we got the numbers just a
matter of
you know convincing the estates because
everything is controlled by estates
fascinating well you're one of the
pioneers who proved that the audience
was
there and it must be incredibly
heartwarming for you to see
this generation of performers that's
come after you because i feel like you
were
one of the trailblazers in the latino
community and then there are all these
folks that have
been following your footsteps obviously
everyone has a different take in it
a different uh flavor but do they see
you and then they all say to you it's
like hey you
uh you made me think i could do this
like i bet you get that a lot
i i do and it it and it and it just fed
my soul man it fed my soul in so many
ways because
yeah i felt very you know i was the only
latin guy in my acting classes
i was always like the only one and then
when i did go to auditions it'd be like
five of us
all you know dressed up as gangsters to
play the next
that's not a good feeling hey you're
all of us like with chains and you know
camouflage
and talking like what's up man you know
what you're doing here
hey louie louis his mom would be there
and benicio taro benjamin brad
the same cats and then if it was a
janitor he'd be there also like in blue
you know overall he's going how are you
doing thank you very much anything cool
yeah good
you know all of us working on our
spanish accents but
you know it it it was kind of a lonely
situation and and uh there was a lot of
glass ceilings and
stingy tokenism back then and to see all
these new latin cats
and girls and young and older getting
opportunities that they deserved you
know
not squandering dreams and not wasting
all this talent which i saw for so many
years happen
well i think that the lesson you took
early on which is just a write your own
material i think it's a really powerful
one
uh because if if you show up to someone
else's vision you're like wait a minute
like this vision's a pretty narrow
conception of what uh lands
can do or are and it's like let's try
and broaden it
i mean one of your most impactful works
was i want to say it was like latin
history for morons or
oh good look at that i got that right
you know you got
me oh thanks john but you know
i saw that and i i have to admit like
even looking over your body of work
i was like wow there are so many lessons
here
like you really blazed a trail that i
feel like other communities could learn
from and benefit from
america was not really just created by
white people as as stephen king or
some of those republican white
supremacists want to believe and keep
saying
it was built by all of us you know by
all people of color
uh latin people we've always been here
because we had great empires here aztec
maya and incan
southwest tribes uh that that became
mexico and then
you know california all the southwest
was mexico until 18
1860 1840s so
we've been here forever man contributing
to america
uh you know we're the only ethnic group
that's fought in
every single war america has ever had
i'm talking about american revolution
civil war there was 10 000 unknown
latino patriots that fought
in uh in the american revolutionary war
and we donated juan middayas of cuba
got two million dollars donated to
george washington to fight the war
from cuba mexico and spain but you know
but it's not in history textbooks and
now that they don't want to
you know republicans don't want to
include us in their textbooks they want
to just keep it all whitewashed
in texas it it's it's a it's a real a
real shame
and hopefully we can kill this
filibuster someday you know soon because
we're running out of time
so we can maybe override some of these
things i agree with you there
the filibuster is stupid and it's
self-imposed
like there's nothing there's no i mean
there's nothing in the rulebook like can
i call can i quote you andrew
yeah yeah you can i love it the
filibuster is stupid
it is it genuinely is yeah it wasn't
even it wasn't even the founding fathers
didn't even have it it was made up by
the senate
nowhere yeah during the jim crow years
yeah it's an arbitrary house rule
oh and when i say house i mean it's an
arbitrary sample release came up yes and
it's just been like you know living on
and on and on
um and if you got to ask yourself it's
like what
body would try and make it harder
for them to do their job you know what i
mean like you know it's like it's hard
enough to get a majority of senators to
do something it's like hey let's have a
super majority be necessary
instead just for like no real reason
right so that so that 35 people
can obstruct what america wants
constantly
yeah it doesn't make any sense the
founding fathers would have never came
up with such a ridiculous rule
yeah they did it you know it's just the
senate decided to adopt it
uh and they cannot adopt it and everyone
agrees interestingly enough
that all you need is a majority of
senators and you can get rid of the
filibuster that's right except
except joe manchin and cinema oh no if
you if
yeah like you need them to get on board
but if you had 51 senators or 50 with
commonwealth as a tiebreaker then you
could get rid of the filibuster
and they should get rid of the
filibuster we're running out of time i
completely agree with you
we got less than we got about 200 days
uh about that right until um
the election for the 2020 midterm
elections and if we lose the house in
the senate we're done
yeah we got to maximize the the impact
right now
i couldn't agree more it's one reason i
went to georgia to try and win that
those seats and oh good for you man you
didn't maximize
oh thank you thank you thank you for
that it's very important like
you you taking the responsibility of
making a change because that's how
change happens
is if we all put it on our backs yeah
so on that topic i'm going to share my
own story and i just want to hear your
story on this side
um so i'm the son of immigrants asian
american immigrants and i
i tell people my family did not talk
about american politics a whole lot
in in my household and it was certainly
not presented as something that my
brother and i
should pursue professionally
that was not the message uh and one of
the things that
i saw recently was that both asian
americans and latinos are the most
underrepresented in terms of elected
officials
of any communities in the country we
were neck and neck with each other by
the way it was like asians are the most
underrepresented latinos were like right
there next to it um uh and part of that
is that
uh we don't engage politically at the
same level as other communities
uh and that's like a fairly consistent
strain and i share with people it's like
look my parents didn't talk about this
this stuff either i'm not even sure like
who they voted for what was going on
um and so you are very very politically
active i'm obviously very politically
active
like oh do you see something somewhere
in the latino community in terms of
engagement
and then uh like how did you get so so
uh activated in in politics if you had
the same kind of experience i did maybe
you didn't because maybe your family was
more into it than mine was
um you know i i'm an immigrant myself
you know i was born in colombia and i
came here when i was three years old
so i i'm a son of immigrants and i'm an
immigrant
um my family didn't really talk a lot
about politics either but my mom
became political when i was in my 20s
because she saw that in queens that
latin kids were not getting
the the library help that they needed
they weren't getting the food services
they needed school the schools didn't
have the supplies they needed
and they broke my mom's heart so she got
very political back then
and she even stopped for aoc when aoc
was stomping in queens my mom was there
with her friends they all helped her
uh i i don't i don't i think the latin
community
has been very political it's you know
jim crow laws were for latin people too
in the 1830s they were all over the
southwest
you know uh no no dogs or mexicans
allowed
no spanish allowed to be talked you know
children
in the southwest and some schools were
made to write their spanish words
and to bury them in the ground so they
would never speak it again uh and this
has been talking about 1800s
all this stuff and and you know there
were a lot they were
governors in in texas who were mexican
who helped
flip texas to america and then as soon
as they won
they booted them out said they were
traitors and we couldn't trust them
so i think we've been politically active
just not
included not allowed you know poll taxes
were for latin people in texas as well
uh you know we're the second most lynch
people in america
six thousand latinos were lynched shot
burned alive from 1830 to 1930.
you know we've been denuded we've been
uh gassed
they they there's this thing called the
bath rights of 1919
where immigrants were the gold standard
from latin america to come here and work
and you know
clean and farm and but they would make
them
separate the men and women make them
both get naked and then they would
spray them with a zyklon gas and the
nazis borrowed from this
you know they would cut their hair you
know shave their head at that lice
and then the riots happen because the 17
year old girl said i will
she did not want to go through that
denuding degrading process anymore
um so yeah you know we've been through a
lot of oppression
we've been here politicized and and
trying to fight but you know it was
always incredibly difficult and
apparel to our own lives well hopefully
we can change that and make it easier
and it is true that right now there's a
movement around the country trying to
disenfranchise people
uh you know like people are redrawing
districts in very dark ways
and you know there's a very basic
principle that most people would
agree with which is voters should choose
lawmakers not the other way around which
is right now lawmakers are trying to
choose voters
uh it's a it's a very destructive
uh approach to governing and
unfortunately that there are a lot of
people that are heading that direction
and it's affecting black and brown
voters the most
um you know that one of the things i
learned in georgia
uh is that asian americans were like the
you know new swing vote in part because
they were
more more recent arrivals there and i
was stunned
at how many asians were in georgia uh
truly i mean i was there to actually
border like that with mlk3 but i gotta
say like
i was like this is like enormous asian
neighborhood the food is delicious like
you know all this stuff i like i had a
blast down there
i mean it was really sad when you know
the six asian women were
shot at that area like uh because i felt
like i'd actually walked through those
neighborhoods
um but they're trying to so sad so sad
the vote
the voting laws in georgia in the same
way um and it's like a terrible response
like you lose a race and then it's like
well like time to
make it harder to vote right yeah
instead of let's come up with some new
ideology let's come up with some new uh
you know models or logos that will turn
people on no
more ideas or policies or maybe we
should have a change of heart instead
it's like oh let's change the voting
laws
uh and and when i was in georgia too
john like the
ads were so fear-mongering it was crazy
it was literally like you know vote for
david perdue to save america
right and then there would and then
there would be an image of
um john ossoff like standing with a
bunch of black people
and it was like like the whole thing was
so it was
so yeah yeah and i got to say
yeah like when i was there i was like we
got to win this race just to show like
that this messaging doesn't work
um and the messaging didn't work but it
came really close i mean
those races came down to you know about
one percent of voters
um so so it was like but luckily luckily
trump
thought he was like working for for them
by saying that you know
elections aren't fair yeah yeah
he turned off his own people he turned
his people off from voting which was
incredible i was like oh i'm so glad
that she backfired on him it
made me so happy yeah those were it was
it was wild man because like i was
celebrating those victories being like
oh my gosh you won the senate and then
incredible
and then terrible things out of dc like
you know i think it was like literally
later
that day where like friends in congress
i'm like texting them being like you all
right you all right and then they're
like freaking hiding in
in various rooms um we like you said we
don't have that much time we got to
activate people uh get some laws passed
get rid of this filibuster do as much
good as we can in the time we have
because
there are a lot of americans have just
lost a lot of confidence or faith
um you know that we can actually make
some positive change
um you're all about positive change
that's one reason i love you it's one
reason why
so many people love you i i i think that
there's something really
important to art
uh creativity uh film
like all this stuff like culture like
you know that i mean there are people
like you that are
sending out these incredibly positive
messages and products
where like you know it's elevating like
people feel from you that great things
are still possible
uh and i feel like that's needed more
than ever
like i think it's gonna be crucially
important in new york city i think it's
gonna be crucially important
all throughout america i'm so grateful
uh to be
talking to you and have this
conversation with you and consider your
friend because you are one of the
greatest creatives of our time
thank you thank you andrea i love you
back man i feel like you're such a
powerful voice
for all of us and for the asian
community for latin community for the
black community i mean
we're all one people really you know
we're stronger together and and i really
believe that i believe
all of us working together is such a
powerful force it's
such a hopeful message and and the way
society functions at its best i mean why
is new york city one of the greatest
cities in the world because
look at all of us it's it's not a model
yes you know it's
it's multicultural and this melting pot
and cross-pollination of
of nationalities religions cultures it's
so beautiful and so
you know it just makes makes everything
so creative and so so hopeful
amen that's a beautiful vision of new
york city
let's make it a reality as quickly as we
can yeah yeah john like with his ammo
thank you so much brother
i will see you very soon love you too
[Music]
brother
[Music]
you